bon soit et du ségur merci d'être avec
nous ce soir sur rtl france bonjour un
plus tôt pour vous puisque je crois que
c'est le début de la famine voilà est-ce
que la situation sur place en guadeloupe
est telle qu'un report de la rentrée
sera justifiée oui nous pensons
effectivement au niveau de la fsu
guadeloupe qu'il faille reporter la
rentrée
vu les taux de contamination et surtout
les tasses de déplorable sanitaires que
nous connaissons effectivement il serait
de bon ton qu'on puisse reporter la
rentrée qu'on puisse élaborer un
protocole sanitaire adapté à un autre
académie et de telle façon qu'on puisse
par la suite avoir une année scolaire
linéaire sans tout simplement se
retrouver toutes les 5 minutes à devoir
fermer des établissements vous parlez
d'un protocole sanitaire adapté à votre
académie
à quelles solutions vous pensez
et aujourd'hui vous savez en guadeloupe
nous avons à peine 20% de la population
se vacciner donc ça serait un leurre de
penser que nous pourrions atteindre très
rapidement l'immunité collective donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut que nos
établissements soit d'outils d'eau nous
savons pertinemment que ça va faire
pratiquement quinze ans que nous
connaissons des tours d'eau et cette
semaine encore nous avons pratiquement 3
4 communes sans eau pratiquement tous
les jours donc il faut absolument faire
de telle façon que les établissements
soient dotées dos et puis surtout il
faut regarder comment nous pouvons
obtenir de collectivités territoriales
qui sont un peu démunis la capacité de
pouvoir faire que nos établissements
soit désinfecter tous les jours faire de
telle façon que nous ayons suffisamment
de masques pour assurer donc les gestes
barrière mais surtout il faut que l'état
prenne la charge d'augmenter le nombre
donc d'enseignants et de personnel
accompagnant dans les établissements
pour qu'on puisse des groupes et les
classes fait qu'il y ait moins d'élèves
par classe et surtout faire de telle
façon que nous ayons 7 10 stations
physique qui est pour nous aujourd'hui
la seule solution pour limiter la
propagation du virus vous avez très
certainement entendu hurler les contours
du protocole sanitaire détaillé par jean
michel blanquer r je le répète un masque
obligatoire dès l'école primaire les
plus de 12 ans pourront se faire
vacciner
si je comprends bien
ce protocole sanitaire ne vous va pas
forcément en tout cas pas adaptée à la
situation que vous connaissez en
guadeloupe
mais oui parce que effectivement
monsieur blanc caire imagine que nous
aurons pratiquement plus de 50% des
élèves vaccinés ce qui lui permettrait
peut-être de faire des classes
dédoublées et faire de telle façon qu'il
y ait une partie des élèves pris en
distanciation mais je rappelle quand
même qu'en guadeloupe la couverture
numérique est obsolète nous avons
beaucoup d'élèves qui sont dans
l'incapacité d'avoir le matériel
informatique ou en fer l'enseignement à
distance ça veut dire qu'il faut tout
miser pour accueillir les élèves dans
les classes et pour accueillir les
élèves dans les classes sans pour autant
se retrouver en situation de pandémie
accéléré il faut absolument qu'on est
moins d'élèves par classe que nous ayons
plus d'enseignants et puis surtout que
nous puissions avoir ce protocole qui
puisse à chaque fois que nous avons une
limite à tête nous nous permet tout
simplement de casser cette propagation
aujourd'hui le protocole de monsieur
blanc caire n'est pas du tout adapté à
la voie d'eau il faut absolument mettre
les moyens je sais très bien que le
gouvernement a misé sur la vaccination à
tout prix mais aujourd'hui envoie de
l'eau
nous savons pertinemment que ça ne va
pas être atteint ce tout de 70 à 80% de
maxine et ça veut dire qu'il faut tout
simplement mettre les moyens pour que
l'école puisse fonctionner en pot
l'instant ce n'est pas encore le cas
justement un disque dur vous parlez de
la vaccination et plus particulièrement
en guadeloupe vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure seulement 20% de la population
en guadeloupe et est aujourd'hui
vacciner qu'est ce qui freine les
guadeloupéens aller se faire vacciner
aujourd'hui
vous savez lorsqu'un gouvernement fait
le pari de la vaccination ils louaient
dû justement faire tout tout qu'un les
personnels et l'ensemble de la
population soit vaccinée très rapidement
ça n'a pas été le cas notamment en
guadeloupe et puis surtout il ne faut
pas qu'on se retrouve avec des éléments
probants nous disons qu'aujourd'hui
cette vaccination n'empêche pas la
propagation du virus n'empêche pas les
gens justement d'être malade et est de
pouvoir athènes la forme grave de la
maladie donc comme nous savons
aujourd'hui que ce pari visiblement il
n'est pas gagné il faut que le
gouvernement se mette dans la tête qu'il
doit donner les moyens à l'hôpital de
guadeloupe ou pouvoir fonctionner
augmenter le nombre de lits de
réanimation et dans le même temps donner
des des moyens pour l'école de
fonctionner et pour que l'école puisse
fonctionner de la même façon que tous
les services publics envoie de l'eau
puisse fonctionner il faut désuet mais
il faut aussi du matériel tels que des
lits de réanimation de l'oxygène et dans
les écoles mais il nous faudra
nécessairement des ordinateurs
un espace numérique suffisamment lange
avec une connexion dans tous les
établissements pour que nous puissions
faire face justement à ce qui est en
train de se passer dans notre
département
donc ce gouvernement a fait un pari
visiblement il n'est pas gagné il n'est
pas gagnée en guadeloupe je reste
persuadé qu'il n'est pas non plus gagné
en france hexagonale donc il faut
aujourd'hui que ce gouvernement et
notamment ceux que qu'avait promis le
président lors de la sortie du premier
confinement qui donne les moyens à
l'hôpital ou voir fonctionner pour
pouvoir accueillir les malades pour
pouvoir soigner les gens pour faire de
telle façon que par ailleurs nous
puissions vivre normalement et nous
ayons nos activités régulières sans pour
autant se retrouver à nouveau en
confinement comme noulette nous ne
sommes plus tôt en guadeloupe merci
beaucoup et du ségur d'avoir arrêté
avec nous ce soir sur arte france
rappelle et que vous êtes secrétaire
général de la fsu guadeloupe merci
beaucoup